it seems like John F Kennedy is a
singular figure in that he was able to
have the humility to reach out to
Khrushchev
and also the uh the strength and
integrity to resist the uh what did you
call this the salad salad brass and
institutions like the CIA uh so that
that makes it particularly tragic that
he was killed uh to what degree was CIA
involved or the various bureaucracy
involved in his death
the evidence that the CIA was involved
in my
uncle's uh murder and that they can that
they were subsequently involved in the
cover-up and um and continue to be
involved in the cover of I mean there's
still 5 000 documents that they won't
release you know 60 years later
um is I think so insurmountable and so
um you know mountainous and overwhelming
that I it's beyond any reasonable doubt
including you know dozens of confessions
of people who were involved in the
in the uh in the assassination but you
know all of every kind of document and
um
and you know I mean it came as a
surprise recently to most Americans I
think
um the release of these documents in
which the the Press
the American Media finally acknowledged
that yeah Lee Harvey Oswald was a CIA
asset and he was recruited you know in
nineteen
57 uh he was a marine uh working at the
attitude Air Force Base and which was
the CIA Air Force Base in you know with
the U2 flights which was a CIA program
and that
I he was recruited by James Jesus
Angleton who was the director of
counterintelligence
and then sent on a fake defection to
Russia and then brought back you know
um to to Dallas and people didn't know
that
even though it's been known for decades
but the it never percolated into the
mainstream media because they have such
a
um you know they're they have such a an
allergy to anything that that uh that
challenges the Warren report
and when Congress investigated my
uncle's murder
in the um in the uh in the 1970s
the church committee did and they did
you know two and a half year
investigation and they had many many
more documents and much more testimony
available to them uh then the Warren
Commission had and this was this was a
decade after the war on commission they
came to the conclusion that my uncle was
killed by a conspiracy
and there was a division where
essentially one guy on that committee
believed it was primarily the mafia
but Richard Schweitzer was the senator
head of the committee
um
said you know straight out the CIA was
involved in the murder of the president
United States oh and and the if I've
talked to most of the staff on that
committee and they said yeah I'm and the
CIA was stonewalling us the whole way
through
and the actual people that the CIA
appointed George johannity's uh who
would who the CIA appointed as a liaison
to the committee they brought him out of
retirement he had been one of the
masterminds of the assassination
oh uh there's no
I mean I it's impossible to even
talk about a tiny the fraction of the
evidence here what I suggest to people
there are hundreds of books written
about this
that you know assemble this evidence and
mobilize the evidence the best book to
me for people to read
um is James Douglas's book which is
called the Unspeakable
and he Douglas does this extraordinary
as an extraordinary scholar and he does
this
is an amazing job of digesting and
summarizing and mobilizing all of them
you know the probably a million
documents and you know the evidence from
all these confessions that have come out
into a coherent story
and it's riveting to read and you know I
recommend people who
do not take my word for it you know
um and don't take uh don't take anybody
else in word for go ahead and do the
research yourself and one way to do that
is probably the most efficient way is to
read Douglas's book because he has all
the references there so if it's true
that CIA had a hand in this
assassination how is it possible for
them to amass so much power how is it
possible for them to become corrupt and
is it individuals or is it the entire
institution no it's not the entire
institution my daughter-in-law
who's helping to run my campaign was a
CIA uh you know in the clandestine
services
for all her career she was a spy and
weapons of mass destruction program in
the Middle East and in China
and there's 22 000 people who work for
the CIA probably 20 000 of those are you
know are patriotic Americans and really
good public servants and they're doing
important work for our country
but the institution is corrupt and and
because the higher ranks the institution
and in fact Mike Pompeo said something
like this to me the other day it was the
director of the CIA said when I was
there I did not go to do a good job of
cleaning up that agency and he said the
entire upper bureaucracy
of that agency are people who do not
believe in the institutions of of
democracy
this is what he said to me so I don't
know if that's true but I know that you
know that's significant he's a smart
person and he ran the agency and he was
the Secretary of State
um but it's no mystery how that happened
we know the history the CIA was
originally first of all there was great
reluctance in 1947 that we had it for
the first time we had a secret
spy agency in this country during World
War II called the OSS
that was disbanded after the war because
Congress said
having a secret Supply agency is
incompatible
with a democracy Secrets by agencies are
things that like the KGB the stars in
East Germany Slovak and Iran and uh Peep
and Chile whatever you know all over the
world they're all have to do with
totalitarian governments
they're not something that you can have
that um it's it's antithetical to
democracy to have that but
um in 1947 we created Truman signed it
in but it was initially
and it has to be an agency
which means information gathering which
is important it's to get to to gather
and consolidate information
many many different sources from all
over the world and then put those in
reports of the White House or the
president
um can make good decisions based upon
the valid information
evidence-based you know decision making
but Alan Ellis who was the you know
essentially the first head of the agency
made a series of
legislative machinations and political
imaginations they gave
additional powers to the agency and
opened up the uh what they called and
the plans division which is the plans
division is the dirty tricks it's the
Black Ops
fixing elections
um
murdering what they call Executive
action which means killing
foreign leaders
um and you know making small Wars and uh
and bribing and blackmailing
people stealing elections that kind of
thing and the reason at that time you
know we were in the middle of the Cold
War
and Truman and then Eisenhower did not
want to go to war they didn't want to
commit troops
and it seemed to them that you know this
was a way of kind of fighting the Cold
War secretly without and doing it at
minimal cost I um uh bye uh changing
events sort of invisibly
and so it was seductive to them but
everybody you know Congress when they
first voted and employees Congress both
political parties said
if we create this thing it could turn
into a monster and it could undermine
our you know our values and today it's
so it's so powerful and that nobody
knows what its budget is
plus it has its own investment fund
incutel which has invested you know made
I think 2 000 investments in Silicon
Valley so it has ownership of a lot of
these tech companies that you know and
the a lot of the CEOs those tech
companies
FSI and state secrecy agreements with
the CIA which if they even reveal that
they have signed that they can go to
jail for 20 years and have their assets
removed Etc
the influences the agency has the
capacity to influence events at every
level in our country
are is really uh frightening and then
for most of it's
um for most of its life the CIA was
banned from propagandizing Americans
but we learned that they were doing it
anyway so in 1973 during the church
committee hearings we learned
that the CIA had a program called
operation Mockingbird
where they had at least 400 members
leading members of the United States
press Corps
on the New York Times The Washington
Post ABC CBS NBC Etc
who were secretly working for the agency
and um and steering news coverage uh to
support CIA priorities
and they agreed at that time to disband
operation Mockingbird in 73.
but there's there's indications they
didn't do that and they still the CIA
today is the biggest funder of
Journalism around the world
the biggest funder is through usaid
I'm the USA the United States funds
journalism in almost every country in
the world you know it owns newspapers it
has journalists on thousands and
thousands of journalists on his payroll
they're not supposed to be doing that in
the United States but um you know in
President Obama changed the law to make
it legal now for the CIA to propagandize
Americans and I think you know we can't
look at the Ukraine war and how that was
you know has been how the narrative has
been formed in the in the minds of
Americans
and say that the CIA had nothing to do
with that what is the mechanism I wish
to say influences The Narrative do you
think it's interesting through the Press
indirectly through the press or directly
by funding the Press directly through
I mean there's certain press organs that
have been linked you know to the agency
that the people who run those organs uh
things like The Daily Beast now rolling
you know editor of note Rolling Stone
Noah schlachmann
has deep relationships with the
intelligence Community uh salon
daily coasts
um but I wonder why they would do it so
from my perspective it just seems like
the job of a journalist is to have an
Integrity where your opinion cannot be
influenced or bought I agree with you
but I actually think that the entire
field of Journalism has uh
has uh you know really ashamed itself in
recent years because it's become you
know the the principal newspapers in
this country and the television station
the Legacy Media
have abandoned their
um
they're traditional their tradition of
of you know which was when I was a kid
listen my house was filled with the
greatest journalists alive at that time
people like Ben Bradley like Anthony
Lewis Mary mcgrory
eat Hamill Jerry Jack Newfield uh Jimmy
Breslin
uh uh and many many others and after my
father after my father died they started
the RFK journalism Awards
to recognize integrity and courage you
know journalistic interview courage and
for that generation of Journalism
they they thought they believed that
that the function of journalists was to
maintain this posture of fear skepticism
toward any aggregation of power and
including government Authority
that you always the people in Authority
lie and that way they always have to be
questioned and uh and that their job was
to speak truth power and to be Guardians
of the First Amendment right to to uh
free expression
but if you look what happened during the
pandemic
was the inverse of that kind of
Journalism where
the uh the major press organs in this
country
um were instead of speaking truth to
power they were doing the opposite they
were Broadcasting
propaganda they became propaganda organs
for the government agencies and they
were actually censoring
um the speech of anybody who descends of
the powerless
oh and in fact it was it was an
organized conspiracy you know and it was
the name of it was The Trusted news
initiative and you know some of the
major press organs in our country signed
on to it and they agreed
not to print stories or facts that um
that departed from government Orthodoxy
so the Washington Post was the signature
of the UPI
the AP and then the um the four Media or
the four social media on groups
Microsoft Twitter
uh Facebook and Google all signed on to
the trusted news initiative it was
started by the BBC organized by them
and the purpose of it
was to make sure nobody could print
anything about government that departed
from government Orthodox is the way it
worked is the UPI and the AP and the
which are the news services that provide
most of the new you know news around the
country and the Washington Post would
decide what news was permissible to
print
and a lot of it was about covet but also
Hunter finds laptops where you it was
the impermissible to suggest that those
were real or that you know they had
stuff on there that was compromising
and um
and we you know and by the way
I this is what I'm telling you is all
well documented and I'm litigating on it
right now so I'm part of a lawsuit
against the dni
and so I know a lot about what happened
and I have all this documented and
people can go to our website there's a
letter
on my substack now to um to Michael's
share of the Washington Post that
outlines all this and gives all my
sources
um because Michael share accused me of
being a conspiracy theorist when he was
actually part of a conspiracy a true
conspiracy
to suppress anybody
who is departing from government
orthodoxies by either censoring them
completely or labeling them conspiracy
theorists
I I mean you can understand the
intention
and the action the difference between as
we talked about you can understand the
intention of such a thing being good in
a time of a catastrophe in a time of a
pandemic there's a lot of risk to saying
untrue things but that's a slippery
slope that leads into yeah a place where
the journalistic Integrity that we
talked about is completely sacrificed
and then you can deviate from truth if
you read their internal memorandum
including the statements of the the
leader of the trusted news initiative I
think her name's Jessica uh Jennifer
disease so
um and I you know you can go on our
website and see her say amen and she
said she says
the purpose of this is that we're an
ally she says when people look at us
they think we're competitors but we're
not the real competitors are coming from
all these alternative news sources now
all over the network uh and they're
hurting public trust in us and they're
hurting our economic model and we have
to they have to be choked off and
crushed and uh and the way that we're
going to do that is to
make an agreement with the social media
sites that if we say if we label their
information misinformation the social
media sites will um will de-platform it
or they will throttle it or they will uh
Shadow ban it
which destroys the economic model of
those alternative competitive sources of
information so that that's true but and
but the point you make is an important
point
um that the journalists themselves
who probably didn't know about the TNI
agreement certainly I'm sure they didn't
um they believe that they're doing the
right thing by suppressing information
that May challenge you know government
proclamations on covet
but I mean there's a danger to that and
the danger is that
you know once you appoint yourself an
Arbiter of what's true and what's not
true
uh and there's really no end to the
power that you have now assumed for
yourself because
now your your job is no longer to inform
the public your job now is to manipulate
the public
and if you end up manipulating the
public uh in collusion with powerful
entities then you become the instrument
of authoritarian rule rather than the
you know the the opponent of it and it
becomes the inverse of Journalism in a
democracy